è la suite i ragazzi ebrei meno di
questo nuovo video sono fabi j
ed oggi siamo tornati sul suo motori
dreams non so non so da quant'è che non
faccio questo gioco ma vi posso dire che
ciò astinenza
i ragazzi poche parole su motori dreams
è questo se la domanda che vi state
ponendo emma ma magari ma che cazzo il
senso ma sto gioco di preciso non vedeva
l'ora di giocarci lega perché mi è
veramente da età secoli che non ci gioca
il fantastico dato così stanno stuprando
a sangue come se non ci fosse un domani
ma io sono caduto il razzo farlo vabbè
bene bene
parte il verde prendi il verde bianco
prendi il verde mentre ragazzine e la
triste storia di quattro ragazzi
ubriachi che tentarono di tornare a casa
ma che non ci riuscirono
per qualche misterioso problema tecnico
la tate che dovevo ecco perché dio gli
attacchi spastici io riesca a splendide
visto giocare il suo viaggio che cos'è
cosa ha fatto il marrone la cosa aveva
distrutto anche ragazze che allora di
togliere lo scopo principale sarebbe
quello di cadere per ultimi cosa che io
non faccio mai c'è il primi te devi
rimanere l'ultimo in piedi questa
sarebbe la cosa da fare ma io per
qualche strano motivo non ci riesco
ancora perché questa è un'orgia o il tuo
bene dal mio bene perché siamo tutti
ammassati iniziamo perché non si è
capito niente
[ __ ] è ma che cazzo sono caduto
per prin fantastico ragazzi se io
riuscissi ad alzarmi decente guardate il
verde guardate il verde questo sono io
la mattina in piedi soldato in piedi
forza ragazzi è tornato
[Musica]
qualcuno di voi ragazzi mi spiegherebbe
che cazzo sta facendo il blu a degli
attacchi sexy io non capisco perché
allora devi venire giovane bravo così
facciamo se facciamo se facciamo 65
dobbiamo riuscire a trovare e bra
non stiamo a guardare ragazzi due
deficienti 2 ed efficienti ragazzi è un
piano malvagio ma voglio provarci bonsai
ho dato una testata della madonna
[Musica]
perfetto ragazzi allora adesso che ci
siamo scaldati come si deve direi di
giocare la mappa la mia preferita in
assoluto perché lo scoprirete presto
allora che io ve lo dico per chi ha
visto i primi episodi non sa già che
cosa sta per succedere ma per chi non
gli ancora visti aspettatevi di tutto
sono ma sono sono non non sono tipo
camera lista ma poi il verde non so
perché lui si suicida sempre non so
perché sono salvagente ho parlato troppo
presto a se io riuscissi a vincerne una
senza cadere come un deficiente sarebbe
anche meglio ma io infatti parla e che
cazzo ci sarebbe anche tanto di
guadagnato ma mi sa che non si riesca o
il verde ha mangiato finace oggi è
cresciuto leggermente il braccio magani
parafango ecco lo sapevo scendi giù
scendi giù notti cadrà sulla testa per
punizione non hanno mancato che sfiga di
merda no no ma che cazzo lara saint paul
stronzo sono svenuto a ragazzi non so
perché siamo così ubriachi o non so dove
sono andati a bere la scorsa notte
ma non voglio saperlo vai vai così orgia
mega galattica era a nonno luigi si è
scocciato prima un gioco ricco albo di
significato per nove verde fermo ragazzi
tutto normale tranquillamente il verde
aveva perso l'ultimo video e di
conseguenza deciso di suicidarsi perché
giustamente i bianco sono rimasti solo
io e te che andrebbe un po di chef solo
io e te ragazzi sono stato rifiutato dal
bianco allora devi andare vai gioco vai
giù stronzo ma il giorno è che cazzo ma
avesse suscitato anche noi siamo bari
alla fine dei giochi tutto il casino è
rimasto soltanto al marrone che non ha
fatto un cazzo dall'inizio alla fine ma
non importa
il giorno che non me lo ricordavo così
divertente mi è mancata in tutto questo
tempo set
ma questo è meglio della breakdance
direi che ho visto abbastanza facciamo
la prossima mappa che è meglio ragazzi
sta andando completamente a caso perché
non mi ricordo le mappe per c'è una cosa
ce l'avevo giocate senape ma non me ne
ricorda la vai gioco tutti giù per terra
ecco infatti sono io in mezzo l'unico
[ __ ] ad essere caduto meraviglioso
ragazzi
aga che cosa stanno facendo di preciso a
me non importa io io vado giù vado giù
grazie chi mi ama mi segua se non ci
fosse un modo per riuscire ad alzarsi
subito ogni volta che si afferrano
metterci mezz'ora e poi essere ri
buttato giù da dei dementi che ti
spingono tipo quello il pene innamorato
del verde ha una posizione tremendamente
sexy togliti dai miei gioielli verde del
cazzo no non c'è più niente
l'agente inciampa su di me perché io
sono
ma fammi capire ma ciò scritto un
gradino in faccia che mi inciampate
tutti addosso beccato nostro calcio nel
culo come si deve i ragazzi bianco sta
agonizzando poverino non riesce a cadere
è bellissimo ragazzi voglio provare a
vincere se riesco senza cadere anche
voglio arrivare non voglio veramente
rimanere in piedi per ultimo che sarebbe
quello lo scopo del gioco
no si gioca psoc ho vinto sto cadendo ma
non importa l'importante è che ho vinto
non so non so neanche cosa rimasto fermo
in poche parole ho vinto così una cosa
io stavolta sto fermo
fate voi ok no no mica se mi butti giù a
fan tua sorella gazich e la morte col
bianco porcata oggi non mi ha lasciato
un secondo di respiro sto stronzo che se
non devi cadere free ok ok se se se
è la vittoria no verde no verde pulito
pezzo di merda allo ragazzi io ve lo
dico questa insieme a quella dover
cadere il cubo è una delle migliori
menti sono le due migliori queste quella
di prima perché lo scoprirete presto
forse fin troppo presente che cazzo
sono nella merda eccolo lì
[Musica]
ne uscirà soltanto uno no quello non
sono io purtroppo porca [ __ ] non c'è
verso e io mi sveglio sulle mine ok
dovevo effettivamente aspettarmelo
ragazza mappa e meraviglia
l'unica cosa che devo riuscire a
rimanere io ultimi in piedi perché sono
nomi non vi do soddisfa
e stato bello che on aids health i
ragazzi e già nella merda fino al collo
quindi aspettiamo soltanto che decolli
tipo adesso ematologi bastardo forte che
non fargli che stavolta no no no morgan
tutto riuscita a cadere alla fine
[ __ ]
cioè è riuscito a buttarmi giù come cosa
fatta l'accordo ragazzi faccio montiamo
fatto di salti ne ho fin troppo nella
svettare abbiamo nell'originaria a
buttarlo giù york
ok ok calmo calmo ma perché se in
decrescente nel cervello e vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai blu ma affanculo sono morto io
ragazzi non c'è io ci rinuncio ragazzi
ci rinuncio bravo
cosa cazzo ragazzi secondo me si sta
divertendo poi non lo so mi di morire di
morire atrocemente cosa certo qua
ragazzi cosa stai facendo
meno male che ha censurato la roccia
mucchio ragazzi prima di concludere
voglio fare l'ultimo perché questo
merita assolutamente ragazzi ci siamo è
sporta che morte nella madonna è che
cazzo e dire che possono chiudere qui
perché è stata una cosa atroce a dir
poco e niente caccia ma il solito sei
video è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace mentre questi due si scoprono
violentemente anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video tratta nella
descrizione sede senatori city
iscrivetevi riuscirvi diavolo prossimo
video ei ragazzi